there's actually other news that i've
been dying to tell you
and my heart's pounding out of my chest
and hit it daryl
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
yep meghan trainor is expecting her
first baby with her hubby
daryl sabra
[Music]
the 26 year old singer announced the
happy baby news during her surprise
appearance on the today show
wednesday to promote her new christmas
album
i'm very lucky my pregnancy has been
pretty easy so far that's crazy i can
say that now
um but i do feel like i'm learning new
things
every single day like i've tried to do
all my research but i'm like
what is this new symptom that i've never
heard about so
yeah i've realized how amazing women are
and we're all like
women are superheroes this is crazy um
can we all just take a moment to look at
how daryl is looking at megan
i'm so excited we're so excited we
couldn't sleep we've been waiting for so
long
cute i'm just having the best time it's
been so much fun to
watch her grow and um
following her today show chat meg shared
this pic of her sonogram on instagram
and revealed in the caption that she's
due in 2021
quote you all know how long i've wanted
this daryl sabra and i
are so beyond happy and excited to meet
this little cutie early next year
we're pregnant you're so lucky
her man shared the same pic writing i
love you meghan trainor and i
can't wait to start a family with you
the singer and the 28 year old spy kid
star got engaged in 2017.
well the ring is so stunning we picked
that out together
and then he was like but let me have my
moment to surprise you and i said okay
and he took his time and had his moment
i did i was surprised that she was
surprised it's so hard to surprise her
it was my birthday too so i was like
this is just a birthday getaway and it
was not
it was more and tied the knot in
december 2018.
when et sat down with a grammy winner
earlier that year
she said she wasn't ready to have kids
just yet
we talk about it all the time but not
soon not right now i said oh yeah
no that's why i'm working on my body i
want to be as healthy as i possibly can
be for one day when we want to have kids
i want to be like oh right now sure i'm
healthy let's go
you know and in 2019 megan gave e.t
an update on those baby plans everyone's
like where's the baby i'm like whoa
well remember when i saw you and you
first found out i was pregnant you were
like i want a baby so fast
yes you know how long i wanted it i'll
call you immediately if it's a positive
sign but like
we go on and off we're like let's do it
now and then we're like let's wait till
tour you know
so are y'all trying uh no but we tried
for like one second and i was like just
kidding don't